what would doom eternal be like on the
hardest difficulty and without the
ability to use the hood
well pretty bloody ridiculous if I had
to guess but as it turns out I was only
mostly right after playing through doom
eternal once on ultraviolence I wondered
how I could up the ante I make things a
little more challenging to the Slayer
now after speaking to game sorts own
Robert handler II he came up with the
idea of creating a hellish combination
of a nightmare difficulty mode and
removing the hood I'm not quite sure why
he wants to punish me in this way but
hey I loved my first playthrough and I'm
not one to back down from a challenge so
screw it I went in thinking I would be
perfectly adept to whatever nightmare
mode to throw me but it turns out I was
wrong first few areas of the game are
filled with enemies that are pretty much
just fodder sure they were fodder that
would kill me in two or three hits but
as long as I kept moving I didn't need
to worry about it too much but I was
already missing the abilities I came to
rely on my - being the most noticeable
loss thinking that I was more mobile
than I was did result in me getting a
little too close to some demonic jaws
and having a jump in and out of me as I
was sent back to the checkpoint screen
at this point I figured I'd might need
to re-examine my approach I had nothing
but my wits a chainsaw and my shotgun so
I have to rely on those a lot more
sticky bombs with the obvious first
choice mod since it meant that most
enemies have been facing for a little
while at least to be a one-shot kill
from range and I could make the most out
of what little splash damage I had but
at the same time it meant I'd be using
more ammo that meant I would have to
keep the idea of cutting demons in half
to refill in mind something that's
actually harder to do than I first
thought
considering that no HUD meant I had no
idea what my ammo was or even if my
chainsaw had a lick of fuel left inside
many times I'd just hammer the key and
hope for the best
I'll keep an ear out for any refilling
audio cue between the sounds of gunshots
screams or Mick Gordon's tasty riffs
as I progress do maternal really started
to drive home the lessons that could be
found in the new prevalence that is at
the core of a game never before was it
more important to make the most of
healing glory kills flame belching for
Allah or bisecting imps for ammunition
but at the same time it wasn't this hard
previously I become reliant on the
lights and beeps of my HUD to tell me
when each ability was ready to let rip
but in losing the capacity to keep track
of my abilities I started to find little
wrinkles in the game that I could use to
my advantage sure I don't have an ammo
counter but the weapon wheel is still
usable so I could rely on holding my
weapon button to check how much plasma
of white full of rocket ammunition I had
and this was the beginning of me trying
to break the game for my own benefit as
you're selecting your weapon the time
around you slows to a crawl and I didn't
realize that I could hold that
infinitely that meant I had a little
time dilation realm that I could use not
only check ammo and select my weapon but
also to take stock of what was around me
and weigh up how to approach the zombies
and imps in front of me I really did
have to think about things a lot more
than I did in my previous playthrough
secret areas were now so much more
valuable as each upgrade extra life or
even resupply meant way more than it
ever did before glory kills were so much
more important now and instead of
jumping bladed fist first towards
whatever glowing enemy was nearby I had
to save them or stack them in groups so
I'd have a health pool to chow down on
if I needed them for a rainy day now if
you ask me a few days ago Dave how many
shots with a heavy cannon does it take
to stagger an imp and I would have said
I don't know I kind of just shut it in
till it was dead but that seemingly
innocuous piece of information was now
vital as I didn't have a clue what
resources were available to me so I had
to make the most of them so for those
wondering it takes two to three shots to
fall to a zombie and four to five an
emperor soldier and once I realized that
it almost became second nature to fire
off controlled bursts so I reliably knew
I had a living breathing demon health
care in front of me sometimes even going
against what I thought was sensible and
ignoring the real fodder to focus on the
big guys and just saving them for a
resupply - or meat hooking my way
towards them for chainsawing them in
half
and topping up my ammo supplies this new
way of playing awesome and I didn't fall
into the same habits as my previous
run-through where previously I favored
the ability to slow down time and use
the heavy canon scope to take off weak
points relying on that was now a lot
trickier mostly because apparently the
scope is part of the HUD so instead of a
sniper sight you just get a blank zoom
in great for cinematics terrible for
headshots stat man I'd try different
rooms new mods and upgrade combinations
and experience ways of playing if I
hadn't considered before I hadn't used
the saving roll room but now it was
almost essential given me one last
desperate chance not to revert the last
checkpoint this experience however has
been a bit of a double-edged sword on
one hand the combat has never felt more
intense every move mattered every step
and dooms ballet of door had to be
executed well or you were punished for
it never had the speed intensity been so
impactful but at the same time this also
meant that at the end of every arena I
was scouring for leftover supplies or
random enemies I could filter resources
which unfortunately slowed the pace of
the game for me to a noticable degree
Deemas always had an energy pushing you
forward from encounter to encounter but
now I was like some overly armed and
armored Slayer on a scavenger hunt and
I'll be honest I got stuck in an area
once or twice because I had no idea what
door had to interact with although it
may not be fair to blame the stupidity
on the game in this regard when I got to
chapter 3 though that's when things
starts to get really challenging I went
in thinking I've got all the experience
I need I've crushed the first two levels
and already have a playthrough under my
belt in the third level of the game you
get introduced to a lots of new enemies
new weapons and even more layers to the
circle of combat in Doom I felt fairly
comfortable with them previously but now
with the stakes ever higher it was
actually pretty taxing on the old gray
matter to not only keep all the layers
of gameplay in mind but also all the new
lessons doom eternal is teaching me doom
in previous years had a replication have
been some kind of mindless shooter where
you get through the game with mostly
only one or two weapons and things were
as simple as go here shoot that but
eternal has really made a lot of effort
when it comes to taking that mindless
part out and taxing your thoughts on
strategy and tactics just as much as
reactions and accuracy skills but
honestly also does that in a really
great way without you having to dial up
difficulty now to be real with you I
didn't play through the whole game in
this method I mean might be mad but I'm
not masochistic but does this way to
play create one of the coolest looking
ways to experience the game absolutely
is it really rewarding to fight through
an arena in the most cinematic way
possible hell yes honestly doom eternal
makes you feel like a bad asset every
difficulty without adding any more
layers to it basically I created my own
uphill struggle because I wanted a
challenge that I knew many others
wouldn't get and a whole purpose of a
challenge is to feel like you've
accomplished something at its completion
honestly eternal is already super
rewarding challenging and incredibly
intense the difference is in this case
you all get to experience all the doom
has to offer without ripping your hair
out as the same arachnid Ron jibs you
too the third time in a row so taking
the sights but go forth and rip and tear
in whatever way makes you most
comfortable after all it's what the doom
Slayer would have wanted thank you for
watching this video on my struggle to
get through doom eternal in nightmare
mode without HUD we have a lot of other
doom eternal content for you including a
bunch of tips and tricks as well as our
review so make sure you check out the
rest of the doom eternal videos right
here and GameSpot